there's a jay-z song  the next time you get a chance my mom is  a little jay-z  there's a jay-z record he want to be  jay-z it's called meet the parents  yeah just listen to that record but  focus  i got a record called meet the parents  with another art so the song is about  jay-z's rapping  uh from the perspective of three  different people a kid dies he gets shot  right  so he's rapping from the perspective of  that kid he's right he gets killed by  his dad his dad doesn't know it's his  kid he's rapping from the perspective of  the dad and it's rapping from the  perspective of the mom  it's [ __ ] crazy  but like every time you listen to it  you'll hear like a new like it's almost  like a quentin tarantino movie but on  record my favorite storytelling record  ever my suggestion just a little you  know an old head suggestion jay-z meet  the parents that'll step your  storytellers up yeah smoke